good evening i'm kurt anderson i'm it's
my great pleasure to be your moderator
tonight um
if you don't know studio 360 thanks to
the alpha piece loan foundation
regularly covers exactly this kind of
thing the intersections between science
and arts so it is
it is why i have uh was so eager to to
do this this evening
the panel is an amazing group of people
uh ken nakayama is the edgar pierce
professor of psychology at the vision
sciences laboratory at harvard
he among other things has contributed to
a basic understanding of eye movements
of visual attention
of the perception of visual surfaces and
visual learning
and
for tonight's uh program most
interestingly in the perception and
memory of faces
margaret livingstone is a professor of
neurobiology at harvard medical school
as well as the author of vision and art
the biology of seeing
her her work is in visual processing how
we see color and motion and depth how we
perceive objects as distinct from their
backgrounds
and and how different parts of the brain
actually
process different kinds of visual
information in parallel christopher
tyler is a researcher at the smith
kettlewell brain imaging center in san
francisco his work like the other two
scientists here involves visual
perception how the eyes and brain work
together to produce vision
the visual perception of faces the how
how emotions and
themselves can can change facial
expressions even
leading into features that don't
actually physically change and he will
also talk tonight about the importance
of 3d
structure in the
recognition of faces how we recognize
faces
devorah sperber is an artist she has
shown at the brooklyn museum here in new
york as well as at mass moca and has
five solo exhibitions this year around
the united states
her installations as you'll see in our
extraordinary involve spools of threads
and
pipe cleaners and map tacks to create
these enormous and extraordinary uh
artistic optical illusions and finally
chuck close who
as they say needs no introduction he is
a painter a photographer a printmaker
now a tapestry maker
and among the greatest living american
artists
who of course appropriately for
tonight's panel specializes in portraits
close-ups of faces and by the way he has
a show that is open for another 10 days
or so at the pace wildenstein gallery in
chelsea please welcome our panel
[Applause]
i wanted to ask first of all if any of
you have a moment the the classic aha
moment
when you decided that this i this idea
that we're all here to discuss the human
face and how we perceive it really
struck you with the force of
revelation that this is something
interesting
christopher i will randomly
choose you to put you on the spot
not so much with faces i had an aha
moment when i was in high school i
wanted to do sculpture three-dimensional
modeling and i had this
sense that in a block of stone there was
something inside it and i
would chip away until i got to that
living sort of object that was
conceptualized in my mind but projected
into the star this was a real a high
experience that lived with me ever since
the the classic sense of the stone
wanted to be
x right no but i understood that it was
in my mind projecting into the stone
and then it having a reality
that i
became the agent of releasing
and you gave up your work as an artist
to become a scientist
that's right you just cut away the part
that doesn't look like a head exactly
exactly
did any of the others of you have a
moment that was was
seminal pivotal in that sense
in in where you've ended up in terms of
your work well for me um
i i've been the scientist and not really
particularly interested in faces but
what happened was i was looking at the
family photo albums many many years ago
with all the members and family and say
auntie so-and-so looks like so and so
somebody looked like so and so
everything was fine we're all having a
wonderful conversation and then my
father chimed me and says what are you
people talking about and i just realized
that he just didn't really get the
family resemblances at all and i said
gee that's interesting so that got me
quite interested in the whole
like a face
processing
margin i want to
and please if you have a comparable
moment
pitch it in but i wanted to ask you
about um
uh
our the the scientific fields
understanding of visual perception uh
and how it's evolved in the last few
years
has as my senses there been a kind of
quantum leap in the last decade in in
the acuity of our understanding of
visual perception
oh dear no i feel it's been very gradual
but
clearly forward
and if i had to decide my aha moment it
would be
trying to link science and art
because
for a long time i did the kind of
research where i study how the the human
and the primate visual system in general
is subdivided into separate streams that
do different things and i realized that
op art beautifully illustrates
the way up art works illustrates the way
that parts of our brain care about color
and other parts don't and so i would
show
off art in my scientific talks and the
only thing that people ever remembered
about my talk was that i would show art
and so i started
showing more and more art in my talks
and realizing that artists
do experiments just like scientists do
and that if a scientist is smart they'll
pay attention to what artists have
figured out and try to incorporate what
they're figuring out into what we're
figuring out well i'm reminded as i have
been thinking about this panel about the
the book that john o'leary published two
years ago called proust was a
neuroscientist making exactly that point
that in not only in visual art but in
literary art and
as well and others that essentially
artists in their
unscientific way are making
breakthroughs
in some cases a half a century or a
century before
you scientists do
um
has the the
ability to image the brain as well as we
can these days
been a huge uh
boon to this
work
that you're doing absolutely
i want you to i think that was a quantum
leap
the imaging the functional mri
functional magnetic resonance imaging
suddenly you can see what every little
part of the brain is doing
in any any task you can dream up
so you can really become a brain
explorer
in a way that was not at all possible
before 1990
and did that
when that began did that transform
what was previously thought or did it
simply confirm and refine what had been
done up to that moment
i think
we're laughing because i think there's
actually more of a refinement you hope
that there's been transformation and
maybe little bits of it
but there's been a lot of consolidation
of what really was known from
neurological studies for the last couple
of centuries
marge i want you to tell me tell us what
what you love about
the the
the way the visual system operates and
and why that is beyond what you said in
terms of of of
seeing the connections between art and
science in this realm
what interests you about the
that the nature of the work you do of
figuring out how this
this system of ours uh works
well we see so effortlessly that it's
hard to recognize what an impressive
computational process seeing is
and if you think about it
the only thing up there is a bunch of
neurons and the neurons are either
firing or not firing
and how do we
extract information from our environment
using light with just a bunch of neurons
that either fire or don't fire
so there's
you often people often think of their
visual system as transmitting some kind
of high resolution image up to the
visual cortex that's represented say in
some kind of electrical pattern across
the cortex
but there's nobody up there to look at
an image
so vision
is all about extracting information and
how we extract information how our
brains do that i think is just really
interesting and i think it's fun to look
at art because artists also recognize
that there's information
sometimes the way they they
make discoveries and develop techniques
takes advantage of the ways our brain
extracts information and you can see
this in works of art and i think i have
to ask for my first there's you have
some children's art i think you want to
show yeah so if you what back one
oh well if you ask any
child two or three year old child to
draw a person
you are going to get
a head on legs right everybody's done
this
this tells us
that
the way
in our brain we represent people isn't
by a vertical
photograph there's there's bits each
group of cells is telling us something
about
who that person is what they mean to us
what they look like but it's not a
vertical image and you ask a child to
draw a person and what you see is what's
important about recognizing that person
what's really important the face
and if we go on a little further
as a child gets older you get a body but
the body is not nearly as important as
the face and just a few weeks ago if we
look at the last one 35 000 years ago
we assumed that females didn't look like
that
but
to some male in the tribe though there
were important features that are
distorted in a sense but also that's
what was important to the individual who
made this little statue 35 000 years ago
so our brains are all about extracting
information and
we don't register a lot of stuff that
isn't important and by looking at art
you can sometimes find out what's
important they didn't think heads were
very important
[Music]
right
[Laughter]
true to life
true to reality
so and your point being that the the the
brain in its
ultimately almost unconscious way is out
of the these these scattered bits and
pieces is
is is drawing an image is is is
putting together the bits that then
somehow the the mind turns into a
recognizable image no
no mind
no unconscious all that's up there is
neurons and all they do is fire or not
and everything you think and feel and
see and perceive and think is you it's
just neurons firing or not firing
so as we discussed in the green room it
is precisely you're suggesting like a
computer with with each neuron being a
binary one or zero
but it evolved
from or two
well um
a lot of
their design differences
and the fact that this extraordinary
uh ability exists speaking of evolution
obviously is the is exactly the sort of
thing that the the intelligent design
folks like to think proves that
there's
a creator an intelligent designer um why
should we not
uh
beyond our faith in evolution believe
that that is so
wow
i'm a scientist and so i believe the
results of experiments and things that i
can see and measure and feel and i take
the word of other scientists and the
overwhelming evidence is
that we evolved yes no i'm with you but
however the the thing you're describing
is which is to say vision is so is so
marvelous that one understands how it
leads people who
aren't
uh scientifically inclined to believe
that okay
but
one of the reasons i love vision is that
you can start with a single cell that
responds to light and you can have a
pattern of cells that responds to light
and you can calculate stage after stage
after stage how information is extracted
to the point where we actually
understand how we recognize faces
so you can really do it in a logical
sensible
wiring diagram kind of a way
that doesn't require anything mystical
no black box no mystical don't you don't
need that yeah
chuck you
specialize and are best known for your
enormous
portraits of faces
tell us if you will how you sort of play
with the physiology of vision and
and and as you were
creating this extraordinary style
to what degree you were you were
sort of taking science
into account as you did it
i um i didn't have
too much awareness of science because as
the lion's share of uh of visual artists
are usually
learning disabled
um
uh you know i never
took
math or science
i never took algebra geometry physics
chemistry i don't know the
multiplication tables to this day
i can't add or subtract without using
the spots on dominoes
so
so i was driven
[Music]
to do what i was doing otherwise doing
by um
[Music]
really the choice not to do something
else i was um
and we may not know what we want to do
but we know what we don't want to do and
what what i didn't want to do was just
bloody my head against the wall trying
to prove to people that i was smart when
i couldn't spit back the information
that they wanted
and
and give them
the answers art saved my life
i dragged in a 20 foot long mural of
lewis and clark trail
to a history class that i was failing to
show that i was at least interested in
the material
but everything that i that my work is
about is driven by my learning
disabilities and my face blindness
we're going to like
it's probably how you say it
prosopagnosia prospect knows you know
this stuff
um
i knew at a very early age that i didn't
recognize anybody
in the first grade by the end of the
year i didn't know my classmates i
didn't know
who they were didn't recognize them and
i didn't know their names
so you have to be pretty charming
and uh you have to uh
rauschenberg who was seriously
learning disabled said
we have to find other venues for our
intelligence but to find another place
to go put that stuff
and in my case
um
i realized that
one of the things that i could do that
my colleagues couldn't do as well as me
is draw
so i used to um sort of dazzle my
classmates with my ability to draw
something even though you didn't know
who they were that you were dazzled
and and i gravitated towards the face
because i was attempting to commit to
memory
the images of people who mattered to me
that i i i swear to god i
did not recognize a woman that i lived
with for a year
two years later
i didn't know i it's like i've never
seen her before
so by flattening out an image
in real life if you turn your head a
half an inch
to me it's a whole new head somebody
i've never seen before
but if i can flatten you out
i can commit you to i scan it i go back
and forth as if it's a landscape
and i learn it like i map
when i move through the world it's like
i'm floating above the world looking
down on it plotting my course
i made the face into a landscape
it's a broad magnalian world like
gulliver's travels where the
lilliputians are crawling over the face
of the giant
they know everything in the world about
that face yet they have no idea that
they're on a face
and so it's that scanning and committing
to memory
of the essential facts and and
of of a person
that allowed me to
uh to get to a point where
uh these images were burned into my
brain and i had a better chance of
remembering them in fact i have almost
photographic memory for anything that's
flat
so you can see the appeal
making sculpture didn't make any sense
to me because you walk around sculpture
the same way i walk around you
but flatness
is uh allows an entrance into it
that is magical painting is the most
profoundly magical medium that there is
there's space where there's no space
and uh and it and it reminds you of life
experiences it's just colored dirt
smeared on a flat surface
but once you understand that
uh you now have a way to deal in the
kind of pictorial syntax
that is equivalent of syntax in a novel
or something else
the part the whole relationships the
marks what they mean
and uh and
it i put all my eggs in that basket
because i wasn't good at anything else
it wasn't that i was
greatly more talented than anyone else i
just cared more just to be clear
once you paint somebody
say you know you you painted phillip
glass famously does that make you any
better able to recognize philip glass
the next time you see him oh yeah well
phil a famous
uh most famously said philip said i love
this quote he said
he is to me
what
haystacks were to monet
or bottles to morandi
subject matter
subject matter endlessly
variable
alter all the variables use fingerprints
use dabs of uh of paint use um uh
uh
in any kind of medium and and plug that
imagery through it again and you have
a whole other experience
the content
in terms of of an image may stay the
same
but as an experience it's different each
time you plug it through another set of
issues
and then and it does allow me to
uh to recognize it
we have a video of you of of showing you
at work for those few in the audience
who perhaps
aren't aware let's take a look at that
now
faces
powerful
friendly
clinical
frenzied
faces by chuck close some of chuck close
artists have been making faces for as
long as there's been art but chuck close
one of the most important artists of our
time has given us a new way to look at
faces move close to a chuck close and
with every step watch the image
deconstruct
a face made of dots and dashes
of circles of colors he calls donuts
a fingerprints
how he paints is incredible that he
paints it all is nothing short of
miraculous
in 1988 a spinal artery collapsed
leaving him virtually paralyzed i used
to work in a forklift truck and i would
go up and down
but since i've been in a wheelchair it
makes it a lot easier if
i can stay on the on the ground and the
pennies go up and down my hands don't
actually work at all
i have no use for my fingers and no grip
i paint with a bracelet is strapped to
my arm and then the brushes uh
slip into them people ask me how i can
sit so close and know uh what i'm doing
and
what i'm doing is sort of
the
visual equivalent of a musical chord if
you think about a musical chord there
are three or four or five notes being
played by different instruments and you
and they all go together to make a sound
and from years of experience when i put
three or four or five colors together in
a square i know what they're going to
read like
from a distance
could you hear uh
could you hear at the beginning i said
it's uh that it's like a the equivalent
of a musical chord a composer can go in
a room with no
musical instruments and no musicians and
from years of experience know that if he
gives he or she gives
this note to the uh bassoon and this
note to the french horn and this to the
clarinet what that resultant sound will
be with those musical instruments
playing at the same time
uh it's not necessary
uh to ha and that doesn't
that seems reasonable right
i do the same thing i don't go back and
look how i'm i'm going but i know from
years of experience i used to make full
color paintings with red made a red
painting put a blue painting on top of
that and a yellow painting on top of
that
i learned a lot about mixing color and
doing things so that when it came time
to putting colors next to each other
instead of on top of each other
i knew how these colors in proximity to
each other
would make the visual equivalent of a
musical chord and there's no reason for
me to go back and look at it i know
exactly what it will read like
i wonder
you scientists here can for instance do
as you as you see
chuck's work and how he does what he
does
does it does it
bring to mind pieces of your work or or
or the way that you have studied visual
perception in in some way that he's
illustrating or he that he has found a
way to some
some
understanding of visual perception
being a as he says an utter
non-scientist
madam
so yeah i've done a lot of work on
central and peripheral vision now i
think we have do we have some what is
that what's next yes yes so i think he's
doing something that
you can see the beginnings of in
leonardo da vinci's work
so the mona lisa is a very famous
painting and i know you've seen it lots
of times
but
there is a no go back
thank you
it i know you've seen it thousands of
times but there's a reason why
so many people love this painting
and it has to do with the fact that she
looks really lifelike she changes as you
look at her so if we now blow it up to
the next one what i want you to do is
try looking at her eyes
and think about what her mouth looks
like so you have to be aware of where
your eyes are looking and think about
something else
and then look at her mouth
and try going back and forth between her
eyes and her mouth
and see if she isn't smiling more when
you're looking at her eyes
so
the
art historians say that what's special
about the mona lisa is that her smile is
ambiguous because it's blurry
but i think it's more than just your
imagination or your state of mind
whether she's smiling or not i think it
has to do with your central with the
resolution of your central versus your
peripheral vision so that's what's in
the next slide
your central vision is very high
resolution can we go on to the next
image
yeah so if you look at the center of
that image all of those letters are
equally readable
so there is a dramatic difference in
the resolution of your visual field
between your central vision which is
very good at seeing little tiny things
in your peripheral vision which is
really good at seeing big things
so your your central vision that's why
you have to move your eyes when you read
right because the letters are teeny
and so it turns out that
i think that's what's going on with the
mona lisa and with chuck close's
paintings is the difference in
resolution between your central and your
peripheral vision so if you if you
filter the mona lisa in the next image
so that you can see what she would look
like to your peripheral vision
or what she would look like to your
central vision if you could see the
whole thing with your central vision all
at once which of course you can't you
can see that she's smiling more
to your peripheral vision than to your
central vision so as you move your eyes
around the image which you naturally do
your eyes are never still
you're going her face her expression
changes because when she when you've got
your eyes away from her mouth she's
smiling when your eyes are on her mouth
she stops and so that gives this
painting a dynamic quality this is also
true of photo mosaics like in the next
image you see babe ruth made out of
baseball cards
with your peripheral vision you see babe
ruth with your central vision you see
the little baseball cards and so there's
a dynamic quality to a static image
chuck close does this with your
peripheral vision you see philip glass
with your central vision you see the
little circles and so as you move your
eyes around
the whole image changes and so it makes
this static image changeable which is a
very special thing that's called the
chuck close program you know
the guy at mit who divide divides this
system the photo mosaics
that's what he calls it so
but what about i came first what about
what mark says
you know you aware of this this this
peripheral versus central vision issue
as you were kind of coming up with your
image making paradigm well you know i
always built paintings out of
incremental units
the early black and white paintings had
units were about six inches square
but the edges were fudged so you didn't
know it was made out of building blocks
at a certain point i began to
to make
paintings that had the incremental
building blocks
visible
the very first ones i did were just
spraying i want to make every square
inch of the painting the same
no virtuoso art marks so i sprayed a
stupid little inarticulate dot in the
middle of each one of these grids
and
i did this for uh
a number of years and i was getting
ready for my first thought drawing
exhibition
and uh i it went from postage stamp
images of 120 dots the minimum number of
dots to make a
recognizable head of a particular person
to a
140 000 dots for a 9 foot high image so
i'm on my way to the exhibition of my
first dot drawing show which about four
or five years work this was about 1971
maybe
and on the way
to my exhibition hanging on a newsstand
is a scientific american
cover
of the first computer generated image
and i thought oh [ __ ] now no one will
believe
that i made these things without the aid
of uh of a computer it was your john
henry moment
and i had no idea that this was uh going
on simultaneously
but
what in fact what i did is very much
like what the computer did
i was averaging together information
finding a a mark that would stand for it
and clusters of those marks
would build a situation that looked like
hair or looked like skin even though
none of the dots themselves had any of
those characteristics so it's exactly
the same system
i just uh i just prefigured it
do we think marge do you think or and i
know other people on the panel have
are are using and have worked with mona
lisa as a
as a
basis for their work
that da vinci intended was was using the
the the dynamism of the eye and that and
the peripheral versus
central vision thing to create a kinetic
sense in the work
well
leonardo wrote a lot about his
techniques we have records of a lot of
what he wrote although certainly not all
he never wrote about this technique
as far as we know he never did it again
we also know that he really liked this
painting he worked on it for several
years he carried it around with him for
a while and then he gave it to the king
of france
who still has it effectively yeah
so the facts would lead you to believe
that perhaps he it happened he
recognized the dynamic quality but he
didn't know how he did it
that's my guess so as shaka's suggesting
he came to this extraordinarily sort of
scientific discovery unscientifically
maybe leonardo did the same thing well
artists discover things empirically
there is no question about that
when they do it again and again then you
say they've understood the principle
he clearly understands the problem i
don't think leonardo understood the
principle because he didn't do it again
right what we do is so close to science
in many ways because
because we we impose
severe self-imposed limitations in order
to
project ourselves into
whatever we're doing and uh that kicks
open a door and we go through that if we
don't like the way it looks we back out
that door we uh
alter the variables again and see what
we can find it's like a high school lab
science experiment and that's how uh
you can progress
using your own um
issues rather than
putting wetting your finger putting in
the air and trying to figure out what
the art world is doing you back yourself
into a corner
i i i think the
we are way too concerned with problem
solving the minute you're uh uh
concerned about problem solving
you realize well this is a problem a
moment and everybody's working on it i
think problem creation is much more
interested in problem solving
you ask yourself an interesting enough
question
no one else's answers will fit and if no
one else's answers are fit you'll have
to come up with with your own uh systems
and if you don't like the way it's going
you alter the variables again until you
find something you want to do
it's
i would assume that it's very similar to
the way a scientist
moves through ideas
absolutely but
leonardo
is famous for developing this fumato
technique of this
real real subtle grading which is what
marge is picking out
in the filtered
the left-hand filtered image
so it seems he was playing with part of
the idea even though he may not have
um considered the juxtaposition so
precisely
we have another couple of images uh to
show a different effect um
not that one
but
that's an attempt to look
i was i was
in there early with a grunge look um
[Music]
but um
this
uh
i'd seen too many james dean movies
this is how i construct one of my
paintings now everything from the
diagonal line down is the first pass
and i put colors down relatively
capricious and arbitrarily
and then on top of those colors
in a series of four or five or six
other colors i i plot the corrections
necessary
to move it from something that's wrong
to something that's right
it's the equivalent of um
if you work with a pallet
that's equivalent of shooting an arrow
directly to bullseye
you hope that you made the right
decision out of context
and when you drop it into the painting
that you made the right decision
i prefer to do something which is much
more like golf
golf is the only sport you can call it a
sport that moves from
from general to specific in an ideal
number of course corrections as you're
moving through the landscape
you may not even be able to see the hole
from the t
the first one is just out there a leap
of faith the second stroke corrects that
the third stroke corrects that even more
and in four or five or six strokes you
place yourself hopefully in the green
and you uh putt out and you place that
ball in a very specific three and a half
inch diameter hole that you found by
moving through the landscape and making
course corrections
and that's a very different way of
working
than mixing a color and putting it on
because it's all found in context in
relation to pieces that are already done
and in
and in and in um
[Music]
anticipation of things that will come
later
and it's like writing or words
any incremental way of working you just
shove something up against something
else so it is as we're talking about the
parallels between science and art it is
it is experimental and it's totally in
its nature
um
christopher you have done uh
fascinating studies about where you add
no way visual noise
to portraits to try to figure out
how we're perceiving those spaces
how did that work
it's actually very rare i didn't realize
that chuck started
with random colors but this is the same
concept so
i'm starting with the mona lisa we can
see the first image and just
putting completely random noise don't
move them for a second
completely random noise on on the face
and what's interesting about this is it
captures many of the
activations that we see in people's
faces in real life
so that the noise is then interpreted as
changes
of expression
and so
what i've labeled on the bottom is what
i think the expression looks like and
you see these are just random noises and
yet
mona's changing her expressions all the
time
so you put the random noise on and then
you find
this one looks happy this one this is
just
how it looks to me and so then i i did a
scientific study of this
got a group of people we can go to
the next slide i got a group of people
to say whether the noise looked happy or
sad on 100 different samples
and i
selected the
happy ones and the sad ones and here you
see them added to the mona lisa so this
is another art form that nobody's
developed yet but maybe
chuck can pick up on it
just just use added noise as a way of
modulating something into something else
i've used noise all along okay so soften
maybe i'm good
i'm discovering something you're using
already so now here i took the top half
of the noise
and and just added that and the bottom
half is the precise original mona lisa
and you see that there's very little
difference in her expression so this
tells me that what the people were
selecting was not what's in the eyes now
the next slide
shows
the bottom half of the noise that people
selected added to the face
and yes you you know that the mouth is
changing expression but look at the eyes
when the happy noise is added to the
mouth the eyes are smiling a happy noise
sorry when the sad noise is added to the
mouth
the same eyes look sad
so
we're projecting
parts of the expression from one part of
the
expression from one part of the face to
the other part of the face and i
conclude from this that it's it's
incorrect what we've all learned that
the eyes are the window on the soul
the mouth is the window on the soul in
the sense of
how we're feeling
and the eyes are just modulators on that
depending whether it's happy or sad
maybe that's why i paint donuts and hot
dogs
my mouth is uh
i'm thinking about eating though
okay
now what what kind of
experimental work are you doing or can
be done or has been done to to sort of
get at that phenomenon in other ways
than
sort of messed up mona lisa's
i mean
is this is this
can we can we
is there a way to describe
neurobiologically
what's going on there when we when we
make such an extraordinary
you know perceptual change from one
image to another what exactly is going
on there it's simply the degree to which
a mouth is smiling or not right well the
point is i had no idea and i used the
noise as an experimental tool to dig out
what was the underlying principle
then it's over to marge to start probing
in the monkey's brain and recording the
cells and seeing how they're carrying it
how they're interacting in different
parts of let's say
the face area to see what that
um configuration effect is is how it's
um
actually encoded in the brain i should
say that i think it indicates that we
see the face as a whole not just
individual parts just by in other words
just by changing the mouth you'd see the
whole face differently and that'll come
up a little later
and and marge when you
do whatever you do to monkey's brains
what what do you discover about what
christopher is saying in this
realm told me i was supposed to talk
about that later oh
you know we we we play it we go on the
fly we play it by ear we could but then
what are we going to do with all the
visuals that i have at the end that
discuss that okay all right
then mark
get to the end if you want but i think
it's going to make justin really i think
that's true
um
devorah
you are uh
an artist who unlike
chuck i would say
has
been inspired directly and specifically
by the science the scientific work
rather than sort of finding it on your
finding these effects on your own um
how did that happen how
did you begin
thinking oh i i'm i'm i'm blown away by
these scientific findings or was there a
eureka moment well first there's the
creation of
a work of art for me and because i've
seen it the way i work is digitally so i
i know everything exactly how it's going
to turn out before i even begin making
it
and when i so when it finally appears
it's big deja vu and i become the only
person who can never experience my work
so then i have to look to other people
and i look at
their experiences and try to assess
what's happening for them and that's
what really led me first to marge's
research um understanding
you know
people's
yeah you know well yeah how people are
perceiving work based you know on the
the biology of vision and then it
informs my work so then the next piece
is more literally related to the
scientific survey
so it's a back and forth but i think
we're all saying the same thing it first
starts off you do something and then you
look at it and you you think a new
thought about what you did and then you
do something else and then again you
look and you think oh is this in the
right direction is this you know more
interesting less interesting does this
open up a new question that is going to
lead to even more interesting you know
explorations
let's take a look at the video of about
you and your work so the audience can
see
the extraordinary things installations
you make
i create often very large scale works
using thousands of ordinary objects such
as spools of thread
[Music]
chenille stems also known as pipe
cleaners
[Music]
marker pen caps
[Music]
swarovski crystals and other mass
produced objects
[Music]
sperber is interested in the way artists
use technology her work looks at the
digital image and its smallest component
the pixel all of my current body of work
is created by deconstructing an image
into pixels and then translating the
pixels into
the palette of each particular material
and then reconstructing it by hand into
the original image
she uses mass-produced objects to
represent individual pixels the thread
spool is a favorite material for this
technique
today sperber is using thread spools to
make a deconstructed image of star
trek's mr spock
basically what you're seeing here is a
thread spool assembly station
and there's a partially assembled map
with each color
corresponding
to a map and also to the spool of thread
and how this whole process begins is i
start with a jpeg a digital image and
any jpeg is constructed from
up to thousands and thousands of pixels
so what i do is i break that
jpeg down into
an exact number of pixels so that each
pixel corresponds with one spool of
thread so in this case this is 29 pixels
wide and that will be the number of
columns on this piece
and i now have a custom software program
that helps me translate pixels into
whatever palette in this case spools of
thread
and that is the final product and this
is kind of like a very enlarged jpeg in
a sense that you're actually focusing on
the individual units of color versus the
whole image
the work is completed when sperber sets
up a viewing device but what happens in
the viewing sphere is that it shrinks or
condenses those pixels back into their
photographic origin
so you can actually see
how radically
different the image looks when it's
expanded and contracted and it shows
just how limited our human perception is
that you subtly shift scale and yet
our interpretation of reality changes in
one case looking at abstract spools of
thread abstract blocks of color and
whereas here you have you know the focus
being more on the recognizable image but
there's another aspect of the sphere
that interests me that it functions like
the human eye in that it inverts imagery
like the retina
and it functions like the human brain in
that it's taking this raw data that
makes no sense at all and it's
assembling it into something
recognizable
this work is a life-size
interpretation of the mona lisa and if
you look directly at the thread you
could see that there is
very little information there but what
you're seeing in the viewing sphere is
how little information your brain needs
to recognize an image that it's already
been exposed to and one of the things
that most people find particularly
baffling about this piece is that you
can actually make out her facial
features in in a very subtle way in fact
this is all there is there's there's no
face at all so it's actually a perfect
demonstration
and how our brain is actually projecting
an image that it doesn't exist out there
in the world like we think of
very few paintings can be transformed
into such a small thread school work and
still function the reason this functions
is because we all know what the mona
lisa looks like
so if you've never seen the mona lisa
which i've never met a person who hasn't
who knows what they'd see but they
wouldn't be seeing the mona lisa
the the choice you've made of of
creating these
beautiful
spherical uh viewing devices and is an
interesting one did you did you think
from the beginning that you would do
that or did you ever imagine that you
would simply have the things
no you know i actually intended for my
pieces to be viewed very similar to
chuck's work he was a big inspiration in
many different ways i won't get into it
because he's already heard it but i was
working in a very small studio on like
bleecker and matt and it was about 100
maybe 150 square feet so my first thread
spool work was six feet high by 10 feet
wide and i could barely
you know even see the whole threshold
work without backing out in the hall and
so i wasn't sure if the piece was
working and there happened to be some
binoculars in the studio so i just
flipped them around just so i could see
the piece from a distance and i had such
a big aha what does this mean kind of
moment that really made me think about
you know what and my brain really felt
like i had a jolt of of surprise
and it really made me reconsider the
whole notion of gradually creeping up
and moving away from an image and and
questioning what does that mean that
something can be so radically different
it to me it eventually
kind of shook down into thinking of
human perception is like being in this
tiny band that we're living in a tiny
band of scale-based reality with all
this stuff superimposed up to the
macrocosms and down to the microcosms
but all we feel is real is
all of us sitting here in this
auditorium and yeah it sounds very like
what you just said sounds like brian
green's description of string theory and
our limited perceptions the other day i
was just referring to that
one one of the things that's interesting
about what you do is artists for for
years generations uh centuries have used
a reducing lens
to get greater distance on what they're
looking at and it inverts the image and
when you see it upside see the painting
you're working on every goddamn day
upside down and smaller it gives you a
chance to see the forms and the shapes
and everything in a fresh way and
problems pop out and you immediately
know what area is giving you trouble so
you've actually done the opposite
you've used it to
zero in and focus and make something go
from general to specific
when artists traditionally use something
to go from specific uh to general
it's essentially the same tool and and
devorah you you're
you some of your work was specifically
in reaction to what you had read about
what margins were right for instance the
piece here that that i did a series of
mona lisa's two mona lisas and the last
supper for the ljubljana print biennale
in 2005 and since it was a print
biennale and i'm not a printmaker i what
i did is i was invited by the brooklyn
museum to do this so i came up with this
installation that was based on
really what happens when things are
mechanically reproduced which
experiences are lost and one of the
experiences that is definitely lost
is scale and we all know the mona lisa
is smaller than we think but actually
when you go and see it even if you know
it's smaller than you think you still
think oh my gosh that's so much smaller
than i thought it would be
so what i wanted to do is to reintroduce
some of these lost experiential effects
lost through mechanical reproduction
so in this case i've reproduced the mona
lisa life size and that determined the
number of pixels or the lack of pixels
that i used
17 across by 25 high
and if you go to the next slide this is
the one that uh no this actually this is
just an anamorphic distortion that
anamorphic perspective is attributed to
leonardo da vinci and i just thought
it'd be an interesting piece to do but
go one more slide forward
one more slide four then we're going to
go back this is the work that was
directly uh influenced by
margaret's work and i i basically read
through her entire book vision and art
the biology of seeing and i thought it
was really interesting what she was
talking about when those low spatial
frequencies and how the smile can only
really be best seen with peripheral
vision so what i thought was well the
viewing device itself these spheres
create a distortion so it's it's it's
kind of making the smile visible using
peripheral
central vision
and so really i think as an artist you
know i'm not like trying to illustrate
your studies but i use it as an
interesting
a starting point to do this work instead
of the infinite numbers of other things
i could do and it also is it's a type of
justification that you know for me
probably insecure or something but if
somebody attacks what i've done i can
think in my mind but you know what there
were some really interesting underlying
issues here that yeah maybe they don't
like the work but boy you know this was
worth doing so
it was a wonderful show too it was
really wonderful the brooklyn show oh
thank you thank you
so and then you know going back one
slide
this is another um
interesting thing
i i don't know if you can see what this
image is but it's it's of a hand with a
digital camera popping up in front of
mona lisa
and i've shown that work here at the
museum of arts and design and a lot of
people are struggling with is that the
mona lisa's armed lava land thinking how
could that be her arm that's ridiculous
but that piece is currently in paris
every single person there because they
have the direct experience of the mona
lisa in their backyard
they all instantly see the joke of that
that when you see the mona lisa you're
actually you know another experiential
component often lost in mechanical
reproductions is the fact that she's
surrounded by crowds of people
and then one other thing about this is
most of her defining characteristics are
missing and yet you don't have to think
twice you just know it's the mona lisa
so again it's showing just how little
information we need to recognize
something that's so ingrained in our
brains it's fascinating have you tried
have you tried it
with less recognizable less iconic
images i have and then it's also a great
demonstration of how much is actually
projected down and i'm sure that's not
quite the scientific term
that i did uh da vinci that that
beautiful drawing that all you know
brown uh drawing of self-portrait
and because not everybody has it in
there in you know close access that some
people you know kind of vaguely seek uh
different
random people from history and some
people know the painting so
or like i've done american gothic where
some people recognize that some people
don't you see them sitting side by side
and it's the difference in their
capacity to project down a complete
image so it's even maybe more
interesting if you're thinking about the
brain in action to have a piece that's
not recognized by everybody
and and what is the the evolutionary
basis for this that to take as as little
data as possible to decide that that's a
tiger in the bushes or whatever
absolutely yeah
yeah it's information processing you
need to extract what's important
i can look at those all day long um
chuck do you
when you hear or read
scientific descriptions of of
the effects that you're achieving in in
the way that you achieve them does it is
there a
hawthorne effect do you change the way
you do things because you now are aware
of
of of what you're doing in some
optical scientific way
um
i don't know that i read that much that
i would find applicable
i think more than
anything
you want to change what you're doing in
the studio
each day and
if i simply change subject matter
i'll be doing the same activity every
day
and that's what gets boring
so i think i'm more driven to find
other
processes
techniques procedures
material scale
to
to change what it feels like
what i'm actually doing in the studio
uh
and and that's uh that's pretty much
self-uh driven and it's uh pretty much a
response to
uh the feeling that you get when you've
plowed that field so many times that you
can do it in your sleep
so i but i think it's scientific in the
to the extent
that it's this construction of
severe self-imposed limitations that
won't guarantee you're going to make
anything interesting but it will
guarantee you're not going to keep
making what you were making
and i think that's how we
so we move forward
when you don't want to do something
one more time
you uh don't allow yourself to do it
the choice not to do something is almost
always more important than the choice to
do something christopher i want to talk
to you about your your theory of
eye centering in in art in portraiture
in particular uh
as as a historical sort of
given practically in portraiture uh
what do you mean how did how does that
how is that central to
portraiture and art
well what's interesting about it is it
wasn't a given it seemed as though
nobody had conceptualized that that was
what that was what's happening in
portraits so
i started uh
noticing that there would be one eye
centered in a portrait and this is
despite every art school teaches when
you do portraits
make it interesting by making them
asymmetric so you you talk to focus on
asymmetry you can correct me on this if
i didn't follow those rules right
but but they they were taught right yes
yes
but nevertheless it seemed as though one
eye
almost had to be on on the center line
and that this was
not expressed i couldn't find anywhere
in the in the history of art where this
was
explained or taught or promulgated
so here's an example with the
ubiquitous mona lisa
although you probably thought that
she was sort of roughly centered
on her nose it turns out one eye is
right on the center line and this is
true of other portraits you see some
some more slides
so here's a self-portrait by tinteretto
his head is shifted to one side almost
as though
the eye needs to be on the center line
and so i did a survey of
portraits over 600 years as shown in
this slide
starting with roger van der veden
and ending up with picasso
and it's not every portrait by any means
but it's the vast majority 75 or so
fit within this roughly
uh
uh 10
plus or minus 5
of the center
one eye tends to to fit
and let's see the next slide shows
um
this was a study that a school teacher
did
she she read of this this theory and so
she asked her students to draw a head a
portrait or a face on a piece of paper
and then she measured the results and
said sent me the excel spreadsheet
and this is the result she got
you know there's a an eye centered right
in the middle of the frame in almost
every case do you think there's a uh
relationship to i know we we choose one
eye to look look at
and some people look at the right eye
and some people look at the left eye
if you split people's image down the
middle and you make two lefts
or two rights
if you are right eye
if the right eye is a happy eye and the
left eye is a sad eye and you're looking
at the right eye you think that person
is happy the person who looks at the
left uh
eye
and sees the sad i think that person is
sad
do you think there's a relationship
between
that i mean are we
are you doing with the portraits
essentially the way we relate to each
other in real life
i i think that's true i think
i i did think originally it was the
artist choosing this but i think to a
large extent it's how the sitter is
choosing to sit if you have a
conversation with somebody you often
find that they're arranging themselves
so that one eye is centered on their
body frame
and that
you touched on many deep issues about
the asymmetry between the two parts of
the brain and how this projects into
asymmetry in the expression
and it relates to what marge was saying
about we have only one phobia and two
eyes so you've got to choose to look at
one eye or the other or maybe flick back
and forth but it's not a comfortable fit
and so this all
all these issues are brought out by this
sort of discovery in the history of art
and and do i take it that your belief is
that it is indeed the the sort of
natural human sitter's choice that
produces this effect over 600 years
i think that there's a power spot and
you actually find this on tv you can
take your television and you can draw a
circle
where i'm saying the eye is and you'll
find that in every soap opera whenever a
character wants not that i spend a lot
of time looking
whenever a character wants to make a big
point they'll bring their eye to that
place on the screen just at the moment
that they're making that point
i've not done a scientific study of that
but that's my observation yes for your
researchers out there yeah there's new
work to be done
um email me
yes exactly
um
devorah
as it happens and truly as it happens
because i don't think this was part of
the construction of this panel some of
your work is also
inspired by christopher's work right
because while i was doing my research
for the ljubljana show
um i stumbled upon an interesting
scientific analysis of the last supper
which places the christ figure's right
eye at very near the center line but
also it's a single vanishing point for
all architectural elements in the mural
and a single vanishing point for the
entire site if you stand at a certain
location which is something not known
about the painting because we all see it
out of context but you know to go back
to christopher after i learned about his
study i remember going to museums and i
thought how did i never notice this
and how different it was to actually
look at the eye centered portraits and
how it felt very comfortable my eye had
a really nice pattern around the
painting versus when it was nose
centered how i didn't know where to go
and so i felt very much like you know
when it was a centered eye that i was
having a relationship or a conversation
versus this fluttering not knowing where
to go so and it is interesting once it's
once you know it go see a bunch of
portraits and you'll think how did i not
notice that so it was amazing you did
and this is a little bit related but
uh
da vinci once said something about to
best appreciate three dimensionality and
paintings you're better off closing one
eye and viewing the work from a distance
and when i thought about that that the
viewing sphere really offers that
perspective by focusing both eyes on on
a single point in the sphere and by
shrinking the image as though it's being
seen from a great distance that that
perhaps is adding to the illusion of
great detail
when in fact the resolution is quite low
if you think about the number of you
know pixel slash thread spools so in the
next slide
so like the mona lisa that's
surprisingly small the last supper is
surprisingly large it's 29 feet wide and
i was surprised i thought it was a
poster really i mean i thought bigger
than a poster but it really shocked me
so i thought okay i'm going to create
this thing life size
and
and if you go to the next
so this is the other aspect that's lost
in mechanical reproductions the amazing
relationship of the mural to the site
that it feels like an extension of the
space and the architectural elements
going to the next slide please
how they continue right into the mural
all to the christ figures very close to
his right eye so that was my
justification i had all these layers of
justification for doing the last supper
in the mona lisa for that show based on
the effects of
mechanical reproductions and thus tying
it into a print finale which apparently
my work was so controversial because it
wasn't really print making in a way that
they're still talking about it in
ljubljana
it's not a bad thing so as i stumbled
upon this survey then it led me to uh
christopher's survey
or research online everything i mean i
couldn't do this work i would never have
found any of this had it not been for
the digital era that we live in and you
know one thing i think is really
interesting is that artists are we're
always affected by the eras that we live
in you know you think two artists have
the same thought one copy the other well
not really we're all being exposed to
the same
yeah it's totally like you were doing
the beginning of the grid at the same
time that pixels were being developed
and yet it you didn't you weren't
inspired by the pixel so
yeah it is in the air so going to the
next slide i ended up doing a series of
work that i call my eye centered
portraits
and unlike that mona lisa where i'm
using the distortion of the lens to
create that real round face in these
i've actually negative spherized at
correcting this distortion so if you go
to the next slide
you'll see that the image looks very
flat but nobody questions this it's kind
of funny that
no one has ever said well why isn't that
image rounded
but again i've really exaggerated the
eye centeredness by put by making you
know cropping the image to a circular
format and i'm hiding the fact that i've
distorted it also by you know the
edges would be very curved in if you saw
the distortion that i put in place
uh so this was an image from van nike
the next one is vermeer and i selected
works from a wide range of artists and
arrows to show you know just how
common this um
the eye centeredness was
and incidentally there's something weird
about this particular vermeer go to the
next slide it's not visible really in
this image because i've negative
distorted it which is then corrected
somewhat but these vermeer images look
more lifelike if they're made
four
four percent negative sphere rise and
you know what i mean like like you're
projecting something in a bowl that can
be done in photoshop with a click of the
button
and we were talking earlier before we
came on about the use of optical devices
and and i thought it was interesting
that that these vermeers tend to look a
little bit more lifelike with a slight
negative distortion of a sphere so it
really for me uh adds you know more
credibility yet it's probably the lens
distortion of the camera obscura that he
used yeah yeah or didn't use it so she's
correcting
yeah
we don't agree about these things but
we've got david hockney backstage
bring him up
yeah i think it's uh you know i think
that you have perhaps
corrected you know we know that that
vermeer
had a friend who was
made telescopes and was a um
yeah so in all of uh delft that probably
was only like
he only had access to one lens you
wouldn't have more than one that would
be
unbelievable to have two lenses so the
same lens has probably been used for
every one of his paintings
and what you've done is correct
the distortions in that very primitive
early
poorly ground lens
and given it something that was taken
away
uh in in the original case
and i thought about you too with the
when you're talking about
noise
artists have always squinted to see what
they're looking at
and it is
the physical equivalent of adding noise
it it does away with it with detail and
it gives you general uh
shapes and you can see the nature of
what it is you're doing so much more
clearly if you squint your iron artists
have always done that and i think it is
the same sort of principle well not only
that i don't know if you ever go into an
art gallery and show any kind of
interest in a painting
but if you do they they're on you like
it you know
immediately they're trying to sell you
the painting
it's not in chelsea they run they'd stay
behind the desk in san francisco
and if you show interest and
really act as though you might buy the
painting they'll take it and they'll
take it into an inner sanctum
and they'll
take the they'll turn the lights down
and as the lights go down you get two
effects one is you get the purkinje
shift of the colors
and the other is that you see the the
noise of your rod vision which is very
susceptible to noise and so you'll see
a real-life version of the kind of
dynamic that i showed in this sequence
and they do this to bring the painting
to life so that you'll pony up with
the amount they want for it
and everything we've looked at and
everything we've talked about are not
sculptural but essentially flat images
flat paintings
chuck talked about how he needs to turn
the world flat in order to understand it
some of your work is about
how you believe we perceive faces
in our brains in 3d well i was very
interested to hear chuck say
that that he he only relates to things
flat and that is part of his
prosopagnosia i haven't thought of
prosopagnosia
as being
as relating to the three-dimensional
structure of the face but my analysis my
data
suggests that we really understand faces
three-dimensionally even though all
studies that look at it scientifically
treat it two-dimensionally so that's
what i'm showing here and it's it's a
it's a thing that's become
uh
keep this for a moment
is this the the cartoon industry used to
draw line cartoons that's what a cartoon
means right but in the last 10 years
everything's gone 3d so
you know
how shrek looks in 3d can i have the
next slide
so now it's it's much more vivid and you
get a whole different appreciation of
the face
and you can you can do this with the
kind of filtering that marge was showing
talking about
in the next slide you see it flattens
down and so you lose that
three-dimensional structure of the face
so i think that
i've talked about the two-dimensional
features and
brought out by the noise but there's
this big three-dimensional aspect to
face perception and object perception in
general which is a very important and
and poorly understood
process of how we would encode that
so do i have another slide on this yeah
so so this this just illustrates this
the sort of filtering process here i
started with a model picture
and did the same kind of low-pass
filtering that marge was talking about
but i also introduced the idea of
symmetrizing the high pass filtered face
and so
now you can see
the
figures on the right that the top one
looks very sculptural three-dimensional
whereas the bottom one looks just
two-dimensional
is there another slide yeah so the these
are shown in full uh you see a real
contrast between the two aspects of face
perception the mask and the features
do you think of that
and what does this tell us about how we
see this
there's more than one way to skin a cat
it it it's uh it relates a lot to to the
literature on in computer science and in
perception where everyone starts with a
two-dimensional face drawing and shows
photographs and everything's 2d and all
the analysis is how close the features
are together and there's no awareness of
the three-dimensional structure
and i have a a whole program to explore
how important three dimensions are in
things like face perception and how it's
a it's another avenue into how we see
faces and objects ken nakayama you you
are
uh
an expert in what apparently the the
disorder that chuck has uh
prosopagnosia uh but
and before i want to talk to chuck again
about the nature of his
inability but
explain to us if you will
what what we all regard as just
automatic and natural the ability to
recognize a face once we've seen it
how does that operate and and
what's that about and is is is it is the
face peculiar as opposed to
you know a leg or a chest
well i just want to step back a little
bit and say
uh
referring to the brain
of studies kind of work that marge and
her colleagues show that in the monkey
brain half the brain is devoted to
vision and in the human brain it's very
largely the case so i'm a visual
psychologist and if you think of half
the brain devoted to vision that's
vision stacked up with everything else
you know thinking all the stuff that you
learn in school there's vision so first
of all i think that we don't really know
that much about vision but we do know a
few things and one of the things we know
is that it probably is many many things
there are many studies that are recently
you can show that people basically are
blind but they can actually pick up cups
so there's a whole part of vision that
has to do with motor coordination
there's there's a person in germany that
can see just fine but you can't see
motion and one of the things that
not surprisingly visual system is very
very good at and very specialized too
and mars will talk about it to some
extent is that this special machinery in
our brain just to do with faces if you
think about your whole life particularly
in our social situations we're looking
at faces all the time we're getting
information about the faces it's not
just recognize basically saying whether
the person believes me or they
think i'm cool guy or whether they uh
you know whether they're happy or sad so
we have a tremendous amount of
intelligence in our face recognition so
it and then of course about
many about 50 years ago people started
noticing uh through war wounds and
things like that there were some people
after they had brain injury basically
couldn't recognize faces at all they
woke up after the war wound they just
couldn't see faces very very obvious and
that was called dub prosopagnosia now
very recently
um
so that and that's very related to the
kind of work that i think marge will
tell us more about that there's special
portions of the brain which are devoted
to
face processing i'll let her talk about
that but it so happens and this just
happened about 10 years ago there's
reports of just ordinary people are some
ordinary people are very very have very
great difficulty recognizing faces to
the extent that
i think chuck is alluding to that they
just really couldn't record many people
have very very difficult time and they
don't even know it chuck knew that early
in his life but i've been on radio and
tv a lot and people write me letters and
say now i understand my life i'm 75
years old
and and so we've done surveys we've uh
interviewed you know
thousands of people and our guess and
it's not just our guess is maybe two
percent of the population has really
severe problems recognizing faces and so
that's just one form of visual
intelligence that's very important and
we don't really know what it is but
probably has something to do with
specialized parts of the brain not
developing and and um
i think that's part of it but we don't
really know all the answers we're just
we're just delving into it right now so
we think that the the answer question
more directly probably are some
specialized parts of the brain these
people are fine and many other things
some people have comorbid symptoms they
get lost and things like that but there
is a a population of just have problems
with faces and that may be related to
the specialized nature as i said we have
multiple sort of visual intelligences
and face processing may be one of them
i just mentioned one thing about the 2d
and 3d part
i never thought about this until this
came up on the panel but we studied
these prosopagnosic individuals and many
of them can recognize photographs i mean
they're not great at it but then they
say real life is much much harder
because i can harmonize a photograph
but real life is really much worse so
i can watch a movie and i have no idea
who the actors are
i mean i see the actor on the street i
won't know who they are and they're the
most recognizable faces
on on earth
in my current show my shameless plug at
um
pace wildenstein on 26th street through
the 20th be there there'll be a quiz
later um
i did something really unusual for me
which is
from the very beginning i painted
ordinary people some of them got famous
on me
and screwed that up but i wanted
ordinary
people not superstars that warhol was
doing or
or uh famous people
um in this show i have a painting that i
did of bill clinton
one of the most probably up until
our current president probably one of
the most if not the most recognizable
man on the face of the earth
and it was a
opportunity for me
to see how different it was
to make a painting the same way i make
all the paintings
with somebody who is instantly
recognizable as uh to everyone
um
as uh the other people are ordinary
and um
i i think it's an
you know it's an interesting
i i did it for my own
uh sense of what this would be like to
do a famous person once
uh but i think it it might offer the
viewer an opportunity to see if they
look at that painting differently
because they know who it is
rather than they
unless they know a lot of people in the
art world they won't know who the other
people well it connects to what we were
talking before about devorah's work with
with a with a the best known da vinci in
the world and a lesser known da vinci
and the recognizability there can i
think you have some images don't you
including bill clinton's wife uh as one
of your images to show the
recognizability or unrecognizability
uh do we not have some i think we just
could well this is uh just that so some
of the prosopagnosics report that even
looking themselves in the mirror they
don't recognize them as uh i've been
corresponding with oliver sacks and he's
reported have said this but many very
famous people can have very bad problem
face record you should go to the next
one here it's a sliding scale though i
mean yeah yeah definitely that it's and
this is a
this is an early version of it's not
chuck close but it's an early version of
parts and holes many of you seen
archimbaldo paintings and some and there
are there is an actually individual who
has uh perfect uh face recognition can't
recognize anything else he only sees the
faces he doesn't see the vegetables
and and then they're the opposite next
this next slide and this is the clinton
one that the statute thatcher and
clinton their younger years and
some of you have done mad libs and
things like that and it's very hard to
recognize the top of flash or the top of
quentin when you combine them you
reverse them they're new people and
that's the idea of the faces that we've
studied uh over and over again that it's
it's the parts but it's also the whole
somehow when we
we recognize faces
we recognize places
not just by the end parts are important
but the whole is important that's what
makes space is very unusual they're very
our object recognition system for faces
is so much more sophisticated than any
other object that we we just process in
so many different ways i'm not sure what
else is coming up here
well this is just i'm very interested in
attractiveness as well in the sense that
what are the features of attractiveness
facial attractiveness and some of you
read this in popular press and things
like that but
if you just take the two faces on the
left they're okay but then if you just
average them it's a really beautiful
woman and and then if you have there's a
there's a male and a female nail on the
right female left the average male and
the average female looks more generally
quite a bit more attractive than your
average than your typica
a particular person and another aspect
of attractiveness the next slide there
is um in female faces it's sort of
degree of femininity you can just take
on the computer you can just sort of
jack up the masculinity and people
usually rate a more exaggerated feminine
face more than a a masculine face what's
interesting is that the prosopagnos and
we've studied hundreds of them have very
difficult time in recognizing um
who the person is but they have not much
difficulty in seeing whether a person's
attractive whether they're more
masculine or feminine so it's it's more
with respect to identity
i have a
william wegman photograph from 1970
in which he took identical twins and
superimposed the two images and the fake
triplet which is the combination of the
two is much more attractive than either
of these so go back go back to this one
go to previous slide here so do you
notice a difference in that checklist
sure see he can he's prosopagnosia but
he really can see the difference in
those two faces so it's not he's not
really face blind he's just blind to
people's identities which is very
interesting the next slide here
so a lot of this a lot of cosmetics says
really to make faces exaggerate the
femininity of uh the femaleness of the
face and that's something that uh
cosmetics experts for
thousands of years have understood uh i
don't know if that's the last one or not
let's see anything else oh this just
shows that this shows you that right
side up if you do mad libs uh with the
left and the right this shows that
there's something called the inversion
effect which is very important we're
used to seeing faces when they're right
side up and just to give an idea what
prosopagnosia is like
just the statue looks really much worse
on the right than on the left because we
are much more sensitive to right side up
faces i think the next slide is going to
be upside down faces lots of celebrities
they're upside down now you can
recognize quite a few of them just
search around there but if you turn the
faces right side up then you can see the
celebrities much more so if you want
just to give a sort of vague idea what
prosopagnosia might be like it's as if
you were looking at people who are
upside down so try that for a while and
they'll sort of get an idea but some
people are and also say that for many of
you in the audience if you're interested
in the subject and i would say
responding to 500 people maybe there are
20 people in this audience that might
have prosopagnosic symptoms you can come
to our uh
website and and and uh check in and be
tested and things like that so this
uh website called faceblind.org and we
we have ways of doing research on you
we'd love you to
show up ways of doing
um
thank you
ken kept saying marge you're going to
explain how this works on the inside of
the brain so now it's up to you to to
uh
tell us how
how that this works how for instance in
caricatures uh which we all are which
are in a certain way distillation
if you put the visuals on i'll narrate
as it goes along supposedly we have 43
seconds can we have something visual
that's going to happen i hope so we're
very good at recognizing faces these
images are coming at you at 10 per
second and not only do you tell when i
put a face in that series you know who
it is right at least some of them
we can recognize faces when they're
degraded
when they're distorted
when they're disguised
and we're better at it than any computer
program
primates in general are very good at
recognizing faces
and artists have
uh start stop
slow down go back go back to just the
two on the left okay i didn't finish my
spiel
so artists
have toyed with what are the underlying
mechanisms of face recognition and one
of the things that artists figured out
long before us neurobiologists
is that a caricature of a face and ken
was talking about the feminization of a
face the way that's in a sense a
character a caricature of femininity is
what you do is you take an average
face
or an average male face and an average
female face and you subtract them and
you say what's the difference and then
you add the difference to the female
face and that feminizes it so if you
take an individual and you subtract that
face from the average face that
difference if you add it to the
individual is a caricature so here are
two vertical line drawings of two
individuals and there are two
caricatures of the same individuals and
i bet you found the caricatures easier
to recognize than the vertical
individuals whose photographs are in the
next panel
so a caricature is easier to recognize
that tells us something about how we
recognize faces so i forget what the
next slide is we studied this
ah yes we recorded from face cells and
we showed them a stimulus like this a
series of faces that varied in all kinds
of flat dimensions
and we asked
what do face cells care about so do you
have one cell that that responds only to
a particular face or do you have a cell
that responds to big mouth small eyes uh
pear-shaped
face and so on and so we we just asked
this question and we found
so you might imagine that you would have
cells that coded so first of all we
found that there were cells all of the
cells in our population
responded to different variables so
you'd have some cells that cared about
how far apart the eyes were you'd have
some cells that care about how big the
eyes were some cells that cared about
how far apart the mouth and the nose
were and the cells tended to be coding
constellation of features which is
probably how we get the the fact that we
code faces holistically
but you might imagine that you could
have cells that coded inner eye distance
which is what i'm showing here and that
you'd have a bunch of different cells
for every possible inter eye distance
going from
jackie kennedy to bill clinton
with every possible with one cell for
every possible distance in between but
that's not what we found instead what we
found was that the cells tended to be
strongly excited either by one extreme
value or another extreme value so you'd
have one cell likes really big into eye
distance and another cell like small so
that means that
first of all that's much more efficient
you see you only need two cells instead
of a
half dozen of them
but it also means that the way we code
faces is like caricatures you tell how
different somebody is along what
dimensions from the average face it
means that you have the big the big eye
difference or the big eye cells pitted
against the small ice cells that is you
code faces by a push pull or a
reciprocal mechanism for big or small
large distance small distance and so on
and that explains one of the most
interesting phenomenon face recognition
i think which is the face after effect
so what i want to do is go to this next
image
oh sorry
great artists recognize this right so
these are a bunch of
drawings and paintings by picasso
but what i've done is put them next to a
photograph of the individual of whom it
is a painting and you'll see that
they're all caricatures
so their various wives uh
picasso himself girlfriend mother-in-law
so on
but they're all caricatures he's he's
picked out what's unique about each of
those individuals and exaggerated it now
i think the next one goes on to the face
after effect i hope so yes so what i
want you to do with this image is see
those numbers in the middle i want you
to so i'm going to blab on a little bit
what i'm trying to do is to get you to
spend about 30 seconds looking at those
numbers adapting one side of your visual
system one side of your visual field to
angelina jolie and the other side to
what's his name
sorry
and and if you'll do and the reason that
i'm having you look up and down is
because i don't want this to be a pure
retinal adaptation i want this to be an
adaptation to the overall gestalt of
each of these faces okay so now i think
i've blathered around long enough and
what i want to do is go on to the next
image and you look at the center can we
go into the next image no
yes perfect now did you get a face after
effect
these are two identical images
which you're now gradually beginning to
see and so you had an after effect that
made you see angelina jolie on the right
and brad pitt on the left because you
adapted to all of the different
dimensions along which these two
individuals
differ
so now i'm done
it's over
and on the
frightening image of brad pitt and angie
and jolie merged i want to thank marge
livingstone ken nakayama chuck close
devorah sperber and christopher tyler
thank you all very much
[Applause]
you